what's shaking your nazis
i'm dave rubin this is the reuben report
direct message
for today july 14th 2021
uh do me a favor subscribe to our
youtube channel tap the notification
bell
share the videos with your friends and
family see what happens
share it with somebody send it their way
and then see if they still talk to you
in the morning
little social test run that for me would
you we got four stories for you today
um and mostly they're related to the
democrats being completely insane
just completely insane these people are
bananas bonkers lunatics
and they must be exposed and we must
fight for the truth
first off joe biden who is the president
uh you know he's got old person syndrome
again i don't want to say that
he's got dementia i don't know what he's
got but he's older and slower and
something ain't right there
well now he's calling these republican
bills to secure our elections
you know bills that include things like
showing id that sort of thing he's
saying that these are the worst
attacks on american democracy since the
civil
war so he obviously forgot about that
armed insurrection
on january 6th that they were so worried
about that you know lasted for two hours
and nobody brought a gun
so we're going to play some video of joe
talking about that and then again i will
reiterate what i did yesterday because a
lot of people were into it i did
what the media on all sides seems to
refuse to want to do
which is actually read some of the
bullet points that are in
some of these republican bills and
there's literally
literally there is nothing in there to
stop people from voting it's to
ensure that people do vote fairly and
that we count the votes fairly et cetera
et cetera
then uh msnbc i know you guys don't
watch this because you're
you're good people you're good sensible
people but a certain amount of people
watch it fortunately it's
it's a decreasing amount of people that
are watching it but this joy reid who i
i talk about often because the woman's
just a crazy person i mean they have a
legitimate crazy person running a show
over there
she brought on one of these uh
republican democrats that are freaking
out about the republican
uh bill the election bill and uh
are they gonna have guns people with
guns scaring people
in texas when they go vote that's what
this woman seems to think we'll
show you that msnbc is basically just
broadcasting from a mental institution
that's pretty much what's happening
then we've got a couple interesting
videos
of the department of homeland security
secretary and then some others
talking about how cubans shouldn't come
here i thought we were a nation of
immigrants i thought we
welcome everybody and if you don't let
people in you're racist right that's the
what we did for four years of trump but
now not letting them in
is cool so we're going to show you that
video and then we're going to show you
how things were a little different
how people like bernie and aoc and
nancy pelosi said slightly different
things when orange man was in charge
and then finally we haven't talked about
him in a couple days lord fauci the
infallible fouchy
uh he now wants uh two-year-olds in
masks
yeah a year and a half later
two years old getting a mask kid before
i do any of that though i just want to
do a quick
shout out to my friend and now
california gubernatorial candidate
larry elder yes that is right larry
elder
the sage of south central as he says
lifetime
lifelong and lifetime california and los
angeles resident
he is running for california governor
he's getting in a little bit late
but you know my feelings about larry he
is perhaps the most
important piece of my red pilling
process in that
in that moment that i know you guys have
seen and millions and millions of other
people
have seen in that moment when i was
still on the left and i said saying to
him about systemic racism
and he beat me senseless with facts
and as i described in my book i don't
know how many people get to say that
their best and worst career moment was
at the exact same time but i really
believed that for me because in that
moment
it was my worst moment because i wasn't
armed and ready to fight back i was just
saying stuff which is what lefties do oh
there's systemic racism and because i
said it it exists
and then he came in ready with you know
information
and i wasn't ready so it was my worst
moment for that regard but it was my
best moment because after that we were
on aura tv at the time we had a
big studio and a big crew and everything
and i went into the control room after
and there were a bunch of producers in
there and everybody was like dave we'll
cut that don't worry we're not going to
air that part you know don't worry no
one's ever going to see it
and i didn't even think about it i was
like you know what guys
if if anything i do here is true if i'm
a decent
person and a halfway okay interviewer
then we have to air that like that was
the important part
and we did air it and the next day
suddenly it's going viral and millions
of views and it's clipped all over and
you know conservative commentator
destroys libtard and everything else
and i was obviously not thrilled at
first but then when i started looking in
the comments section i saw people saying
hey you know dave
seemed like he listened there seemed
like he was open to new information like
let's kind of see what happens
and well flash forward four years later
i think you guys have seen what happened
so it was really my best and worst
moment at the same time
in any event larry is a lifelong los
angeles resident
he is i would say he's more on the
libertarian side
of a conservative which is pretty much
where i fall
he wants to open up the state he wants
to get rid of regulation he wants to
reduce
taxes he wants to basically reverse
everything that gavin newsom
has done so i'm going to obviously have
him back on the show to discuss the
campaign and i hope he's
not getting in too late and we shall see
what happens and you know in essence i'm
not i'm not endorsing anyone just this
second
um but in essence he has my support
until it goes
awry right like unless he proves that
there's some reason that i shouldn't
support him i know him to be a good
decent man he's a friend we've broken
bread
many times and i'm just excited that a
good human being who knows his stuff and
cares deeply
about los angeles about california is
getting in and we shall see what happens
okay first story joe biden is
freaking out about these republican
election bills now to be clear and i'm
going to get into the specifics after we
show you the biden video
these election bills that the
republicans are putting up include
controversial things like having an id
and that they're going to have cameras
when people are counting votes and that
we should have paper trails
so that your touch screen actually
matches the paper so that we will be
able to audit
properly there is literally nothing in
these republican bills
that stops anyone from voting that
intimidates anyone from voting
that doesn't allow people of a certain
color or economic class to vote or
anything else
but the democrats are now doing what
they do with everything
in cahoots with the mainstream media the
corporate press
which is just saying a whole
bunch of [ __ ] and what that [ __ ]
is
is that this is an attack on democracy
while they are the ones actually
attacking democracy because they don't
want
our elections to be able to be audited
and able to be accounted for so listen
to joe biden
so hear me clearly
there's an unfolding assault
taking place in america today an attempt
to suppress and subvert
the right to vote and fair and free
elections
an assault on democracy an assault on
liberty
an assault on who we are
who we are as americans for make no
mistake
bullies and merchants of fear peddlers
of lies
are threatening the very foundation of
our country
it gives me no pleasure to say this i
never thought my entire career i'd ever
have to say it
we're facing the most significant test
of our democracy
since the civil war that's not hyperbole
since the civil war
the confederates back then never
breached the capitol
as insurrectionists did on january the
6th
i am sorry but the president of the
united states is an abject
liar like there is no other way to put
it he says there is an unfolding assault
yeah it's from you guys you guys are the
ones
who are trying to make sure that anyone
can vote without id
that we won't have paper trails that
there won't be cameras so we can
actually see if vote counting is fair
notice he doesn't bring up any of the
specific things in the bills
and this is what the democrats keep
doing and unfortunately because the
mainstream media is so awful
nobody calls them out on it they never
say what's in the bills but the bills
are racist
the bills are an assault on democracy
and an affront
to the republican free societies and the
rest of it
he talks about peddlers of lies he is
the prime peddler
of the lie the big lie it's the big lie
that these bills are somehow racist and
anti-american
and everything else uh just to be very
very clear and if you did not see our
show yesterday
go watch it and if you if you do dare be
on twitter i sent out a twitter thread
with the shorter versions of the videos
so that you can share them these bills
including hb3 which is the one in texas
that everyone's freaking out about right
now
include that you would have to have
voter ids and not even just driver's
licenses because not everybody has it
but you could even use
just the last part of your social
security number
so that we can make sure that if you're
a citizen who's supposed to vote you can
vote and that say somebody
can't vote 10 times and pretend to be
ten different people right
uh it allows for extra time to vote it
allows for cameras while counting as i
said
it encourages employers to offer more
time so people can vote on election day
and a series of other things like that
the only
reason here's the bumper sticker of
today's show
the only reason the democrats don't want
voter id
and don't want a paper trail and don't
want cameras
when you're counting votes and
everything else i just mentioned
is because the democrats want to cheat
that is i'm sorry
but that is just the truth otherwise
none of this makes any sense
right like why would they not be for
these things if they want free and fair
elections that are that we can feel good
about feel like the system works
feel pride in america and that one
person one vote
is actually what's happening why would
you not want to secure our elections
they're trying to destroy our elections
while they're claiming we're trying to
destroy our elections and by the way
this this thing about
this is the worst assault since the
civil war so again
these are the same people who just said
that right they just shot their load on
that one
on the january sixth thing right that
was the worst a front since the civil
war they keep forgetting about 9 11. i
was in new york city
during 9 11. i remember what that was
like when two planes crashed
into the world trade center and killed
almost 3 000 people and the city
was not right for months and months
after that i lived on 90th and first if
you
if you want to check a map of new york
city or you know a little something
about new york city
you know uh downtown where the towers
were is extremely far it's sort of the
polar opposite part of manhattan
then 90th and first where i used to live
by by gracie mansion the the mayor's
mansion
and for weeks after that you could smell
soot and you could smell debris
and the city was just completely
paralyzed do you remember that joe do
you remember that
or somehow is having to show an id
more an affront to american democracy
than that terrorist attack i mean these
people are just
patently ridiculous i will say this and
this is a little offshoot of something
that i've heard a few people say walter
kern implied this on our show on friday
author walter kern and my friend michael
malus who obviously
does the show often that they're getting
so hysterical right now that it does
kind of show that we're winning like i
know it's hard it's hard to see that
because when you're just being
like like when you have a bunch of like
[ __ ] just being poured on you
all the time it feels pretty awful right
nobody wants [ __ ] pour it all over
their head
all the time every day but they're lies
when it comes to
calling everyone racist and their lies
when it
comes to election integrity and their
lives when it comes to virtually
every issue systemic racism and critical
race theory
in schools and everything else that i
cover here every day their lives are
getting so over the top
that i really do think they are starting
to lose the narrative right now
and and the question is because the the
machine whatever that thing is
it's evil and it's always a little bit
ahead of us right it's always able to
somehow survive everything right if you
think about this in
a matrix style situation um like what's
its next move
is it going to uh just start having to
ban more people because there's too many
people
saying things right now um you know
there's too many people like wait a
minute the democrats are lying critical
race theory is in schools the
republicans are trying to secure
elections so you're gonna have to shadow
ban people are you gonna have to do more
algorithmic tricks
is google gonna have to reorder
information so that we're not gonna be
able to find the truth like
how how often how many times can we
debunk
the nonsense on cnn or the nonsense on
msnbc
and then more and more people see it
because more of us are online now than
obviously watching those
overly produced ridiculous shows well
then what is the system's next move i
don't know it could be to boot everybody
i don't know they could just start
booting more people or making sure you
guys don't see these videos
you know how many how often do i say you
guys subscribe you click the
notification bell and you just don't see
our videos in your feed like
we don't know what's going on and
because big tech has less transparency
than the government
we got we got a real tightly wound
problem you see what i'm saying anyway
they're just liars but the hope
part of this is that as the lies
get bigger they are getting debunked in
real time more and more and more
uh and not to make this a commercial but
i would say this is why just create a
free account
at reubenreport.locals.com you don't
have to pay a dime if you don't want to
interact with me
or get any of the early stuff or
anything like that but i probably have
limited time
on big tech right like most of us that
are doing anything honest and decent
probably do
so if you just create a free account
then i'll at least be able to send push
notifications to you and contact you
because who the hell knows what's going
to happen because i don't think they can
allow this to last much longer
it's like everything joe biden said
right there is a lie and if and if cnn
won't call him out on the lie and msnbc
won't call him out on the lie
and and all the other places the
mainstream places won't call him out
alive but then all of us that are online
know that it's a lie it's like how long
is that situation tenable
i suspect not much longer actually um
all right let's move on to msnbc
i know it's a completely bananas network
and i know you guys don't watch it and
you shouldn't watch it and i know that
most of the hosts there
are mentally ill crazy people but this
joy read really takes the cake
on this stuff she just brings on
conspiracy theorists all the time
she makes up nonsense related to
critical race theory she calls everyone
that doesn't agree with her
a white supremacist and the rest of it
well yesterday she had texas state
house democrat dean sanfronia thompson
on to discuss what's going on in texas
now you may know
that a bunch of the texas state
democrats have
fled they've literally fled texas and
they've gone to dc
uh because they don't want to have to
vote on this bill and now it's getting
messy in texas because abbott is saying
that they could
they could be arrested on return like
it's a whole crazy situation over there
but notice of course that they don't
tell you what's in the bill they just
tell you it's evil and racist and scary
and now
there's going to be scary people with
guns stopping people from voting
take a look now they put coal watchers
in minority areas and they are normal
people of different nationalities in the
areas that they place them
and they are there to intimidate the
workers
not the workers but then intimidate the
voters and when persons
people walk into a poll and they see
these strange persons in their polling
place
looking at them mean spirited uh
it's frightening and sometimes they may
just get up and walk out
are they allowed to be armed can they
can those poll watchers be armed
well uh that's a good question
uh particularly since we have just
passed the
permit-less gun bill we know that the
the uh the
the person themselves who uh presides
over the poll
can in fact have a gun but whether the
poll walkers would be permitted to have
one
is another question i would predict that
they probably
they probably could i'm sorry these are
crazy people that live
in a fictitious world okay there are
strange people
looking mean and they might have guns
now
putting aside just the general insanity
of that like i know
that i guess if you're watching msnbc
that sounds like something like oh my
god
because of these republican bills the
republican bill must
have some sort of provision that says
that strange people with mean
looks that they are going to be standing
outside the polls well
let's even pretend that that was true
that there was something in the bill
that encouraged strange people with mean
looks to stand outside the polling place
and let's
even say that those people had guns
you're not going to believe this but
those people wouldn't know i mean first
off it's just not true
but those people would not know which
way you're going to vote so you'd still
be allowed to vote
what they are doing is the worst sort of
fear-mongering
craziness possible they don't mention
anything
that's in the bill they mention things
that they purport to be in the bill that
involve
strange people and the way they might
look at you
and then oh people have guns in texas
and then we're going to allow for guns
there
and then i guess they'll just be
shooting democrats right like we're just
gonna people
outside who would you vote for democrat
like come on
they just they're just don't watch msnbc
i know you don't
i know you don't but if you have a
friend that watches msnbc
you know what if you have a friend that
watches msnbc
and you send them an email and you say
to them
dear so and so i don't watch you want
you to watch msnbc anymore it's not good
for you
okay and then they write back to you and
then they say
okay i won't watch it anymore because
you've given them a couple reasons give
them some bullet points maybe link them
to one of my videos
for the first 50 people that do that
and we get responses where you actually
they say to you okay
i've decided i'm not going to watch
msnbc anymore we'll give you
i don't know we'll give you a couple
months free at rubinreport.locals.com
because we must
bring sanity back to america and what
you just saw there is a completely
fictitious made-up story being delivered
by joy reid talking to this democrat who
fled the state
fled the state shirked her
responsibilities as
a democratic congresswoman from texas
just like a whole bunch of the other
ones did
so that she can go on these tv shows and
pretend that strange people
with evil they're gonna give them the
evil eye
lordy lordy all right it gets crazier so
uh look there's this whole situation
going down
in cuba the people of cuba want to be
free it really is as simple as that like
i don't need to give you
much more detail on the story than that
the people live under a communist regime
people don't have ownership they don't
have the ability to spend money freely
and actually
build generational wealth and make all
of the great successes that you can do
here in a capitalist country
and as i mentioned i was just in florida
and miami this past weekend there are
hundreds and thousands of if not
hundreds of thousands
of cuban immigrants there they love
america they are so proud of america
they are the reverse of everything the
mainstream tells you
and they are hard working they're doing
all the tough jobs so they can build
better lives for their families and just
listen to marco rubio's personal story
okay or mayor suarez there or or a
litany of other people okay
so the cubans want to be free so our
administration is pretending that no
these
these uh rallies where they're literally
yelling
freedom they are yelling freedom and
liberty those are the buzzwords that
they're yelling
it's not really about freedom or liberty
from communism it's because they want
more coveted vaccinations that's what
these ridiculous
people in this clown administration that
we have
are doing well now department of
health secretary ali majorcas
uh is got a warning for cuban refugees
he don't want him let's take a look
allow me
to be clear if you take to the sea
you will not come to the united states
the time is never right to attempt
migration
by sea to those who risk their lives
doing so this risk is not worth taking
again i repeat do not risk your life
attempting
to enter the united states illegally you
will not come
that's department of homeland security
by the way i think i might have said
health security there
but boy that does sound awfully racist
and mean i thought
i thought we're america where anyone can
come here at any time and if we don't
let you in that we're racist that's the
game we were playing under trump right
like you got to open up those borders
let anybody in don't really ask them
anything
give them all the services you know come
on america
it's horrible everyone join us you may
also remember
this lady tackling kamala uh just a few
weeks ago
talking about our border i want to be
clear to folks in this region
who are thinking about making that
dangerous trek
to the united states mexico border
do not come do not come
we should have played that video of
trump saying i'm gonna come we should
have done that
we'll link that together after there's a
great meme of that where she's going
do not come do not come but trump goes
i'm gonna come
anyway she's a racist obviously by her
own words right because when trump was
saying don't come or you have to come
trump actually never told immigrants not
to come by the way if you listen to all
the videos of trump on this stuff
he would say we have to have a legal
process we have to have a border so we
know who's coming and then we can have a
legal process to allow immigrants to
come
so look by their own words our
department of homeland security and our
vice president
are racists and they obviously hate
cuban people now in a way they do hate
cuban people because
as i just said cubans come to america
and love the american dream
perhaps more than any other immigrant
group right
like maybe not more than any other
immigrant group of all time because we
had plenty of immigrant groups that have
come
over decades and loved it but like as
first generations won
first generation immigrants in a modern
context in the context of 2021 i don't
know of a group that
loves america more there might be from
maybe somewhere in africa that come and
work very hard and
you know some from mexico but like
cubans come and they love america and
it's pretty freaking spectacular
well now let's show you some video of
bernie sanders
and aoc and nancy pelosi talking about
trump's
immigration policy and i think you'll
see that it was
a little bit different from these types
of people when orange man
was in charge we will rescind all of
trump's
hateful and racist
ex immigration executive orders
states he has a proven track record of
discrimination
against anybody who's really non-white
in the united states president
first assumed office with his with his
uh racist and violent rhetoric
it's about keeping you know make america
you know his hat
make america white again they want to
make sure
that people certain people are counted
you know there's a line that i quote
every now and again from my friend
dennis prager and what he's been saying
for years is that the difference between
the left and the right
is that the right thinks that the left
is wrong and the left
think that thinks that the right is evil
and
i think that was the right estimation
for a long time but i'm actually
starting to think that these people are
evil
at what point if you lie about
everything
all the time if you lie about what
someone else is doing while you're doing
that very same thing
especially as a public person right as
people in charge of policy and the
direction of the country
at what point is this just blatantly
evil
so unless bernie sanders now wants to
say that the biden administration
is full of hatred and racist as he just
said
there about donald trump or aoc said
that
trump's policies are discriminatory and
they're racist and violent
and then of course nancy pelosi
basically implied that trump supporters
are all white supremacists well they
obviously all should be completely
against what kamala's saying to
uh you know people in guatemala that's
what that video is from and from south
america coming here she's don't come
don't come okay so you're racist against
those people
and uh obviously the department of
homeland security
threatening these people who are under
the attack of a communist regime well
obviously the department of homeland
security
is racist and evil and everything else
now of course it's not because
it's racist and evil it's because we
have a country and we have to figure out
how many people can be here and we've
also got some problems right now
and the economy was wrecked because of
the pandemic or whatever you want to
call it at this point and everything
else
so you see why this is all just nonsense
and they just
they just don't stop they just don't
stop so our work as i always say is cut
out for us
because if you're going to tell the
truth in a time of massive lies
uh it ain't gonna be that easy but i
have nothing better to do
so we're gonna just keep going but these
are bad these are just not good people
like some actually someone in the
comments actually it's easy as i always
say it's easier for me to read them in
locals that's where i can engage with
you guys
but somebody give me the most charitable
interpretation of what these people are
doing
like when it comes to the election law
just even the stories we've just covered
today
they're blatantly lying about the
election law from biden
all the way down and they're blatantly
lying about our immigration policies
from biden all the way down what is the
most charitable way like am i being a
partisan
hack right now when i'm calling this out
and showing you this hypocrisy
is there a way do i have a blind spot
here because i'm just so fed up with the
democrats please show it to me if there
is
um by the way if you want to have a
little more context on this
uh i did an interview with samuel
rodriguez who i think has worked for
four administrations and
with immigration if i'm not mistaken and
we do
a whole chunk of it about a half hour on
the democrat immigration hypocrisy and
how that donald trump was willing to
make
massive deals with the democrats and
that rodriguez himself took one of the
deals
to the office of chuck schumer and chuck
schumer basically said to him
yeah this is good but we're not going to
give trump an inch because we don't want
trump to get a win
these are just facts these are just
facts so somebody tell me the charitable
version of what i'm doing are they just
lying about absolutely everything or am
i missing something because i would love
to be missing something
i wish these people were not as bad as i
now believe them to be
whether it's joy reid lying about guns
and scary people
with voting laws and biden with the
voting laws or what they're saying about
immigration or anything else
speaking about uh speaking of liars
let's finish up with the infallible
fouchy so he now wants children
over two years old to mask up or take
the vaccine
no children are dying because of this
thing it is
extraordinarily extraordinarily rare
adults
even it's about 97.5 to 99 percent
that you will survive if you get coveted
you all know the stuff about the
comorbidities
and being overweight and diabetes and
everything else on top of the fact that
now many of us have had covet and have
natural antibodies
and a huge amount of people have now
been vaccinated and we're supposed to
believe that the vaccines work although
now they're telling us
people are going to have to get booster
shots every year and everything else
well now
fauci wants kids i mean really think
before you watch this video
whatever whatever little child you know
in your life i just spent some time with
my sister
and her great kids she's got a
six-year-old and a two-year-old
this two-year-old boy like this is not a
kid who should be wearing a mask this is
a kid who should be running free and
playing with blocks and destroying
stuff and going crazy and running around
his house in a scooter which mom wasn't
thrilled about but you know what are you
gonna do
anyway here's lord fauci you know that
children under the age of 12
who are not eligible for the vaccines
generally do not
get sick don't get coveted or don't get
us ill with it
but what does this spread of the delta
variant mean for them
for the children under the age of 12 and
what's the timeline for when they might
become eligible
well a couple of questions and the
answers are
the children who are not able to get
vaccinated because of their age
should follow their parents should
follow with them the guidelines
of the cdc that unvaccinated children
of a certain age greater than two years
old should be wearing masks
no doubt about that that's the way to
protect them from getting infected
because if they do
they can then spread the infection to
someone else
so the cdc guidelines for unvaccinated
people including children
are not changed at all we are currently
doing
we being the federal government together
in collaboration
with the pharmaceutical companies age
de-escalation
studies namely looking at the safety
and the immunogenicity of vaccines in
children from 12 to 9 years old
and from 9 to 6 then from six to two
years old and then ultimately
from six months to two years old
dystopia man we live in
a modern dystopia that really is the
truth okay so a couple things here first
off andrea mitchell
that's msnbc by the way andrea mitchell
she says something interesting in the
beginning she basically says kids don't
get sick and then in the next breath she
goes when can the kids get vaccinated
she links that then to the delta variant
she doesn't give you any data on the
delta variant right
nothing and this is what they do with
everything they don't give you any data
points
they just say things so she goes kids
don't get sick when can they all get
vaccinated because of delta and it's
like well well is something going on
with delta that we need to know is it
killing a lot of kids
then they're saying if they get this is
what
uh fauci saying he's saying if they get
infected meaning the kids
they can spread it now that's probably
true right like
it is possible that kids can get coveted
actually my
six-year-old niece and my two-year-old
nephew who i just mentioned they had
coveted they did the quarantine the
whole thing they were sick for a few
days and then
everything was okay my sister got it
when they got it and actually my
brother-in-law who lived in a very small
house with them did not get it these are
all just
things like i'm just putting out a
little bit of a little bit of personal
stuff right there
um but the point is okay let's say a
two-year-old got it
it might give it to another two-year-old
and another two year old another two but
is there any evidence that those kids
are
gonna die is there any evidence they're
going to have long-term effects or
anything else notice they don't tell you
any of those things
so his answer is let's do these studies
to inject
two-year-olds with this stuff and in the
meantime
follow the cdc guidelines that have been
completely all over the map and often
contradictory and everything else
um or put your kids in masks
so two-year-olds and three-year-olds and
everything else should be in mass you
know i was in
uh universal studios we took my my niece
and nephew to universal studios about a
week and a half ago
here in los angeles and i would say half
the kids there were in masks
so you've got kids walking into harry
potter land kids on
outdoor roller coasters kids that should
be laughing and smiling and running
around and it's la in the summer it was
like 95 degrees
everyone's dripping with sweat you've
got adults who i guess have been
vaccinated not in mass
and you've got kids who are dressed up
as harry potter or hermione whatever her
name is and whoever
and those are heavy costumes that
they're wearing dressed up as wizards
hermione granger thank you
um you know i'm a star wars guy more of
a robot guy than the wizards it's a
little ah the wizards whatever
oh you got a little stick and you can
fly on a broom zippity doodle it's like
give me a lightsaber all right but
but the point is they're ruining
children they're ruining children
fauci is just ridiculous i i can't
believe that biden's my president and
fauci is my
chief medical officer like what is going
on here what is going on here anyway
people
as i said yesterday i hope when you
watch the show you feel a little dose of
sanity
and uh and again they're going crazy
because people are waking up so let's
just keep pushing let's just keep
pushing let's just keep doing this
together
that's what we can do uh we got a friday
round table for you i know we haven't
done it in the last couple weeks because
of some of my travels
rogan o'hanley will be on the show
lawyer ron coleman and ali stuckey
from the blaze will be recapping
everything going on in the world
i suspect some of the things we spoke
about today will continue to unfold
and part two of my interview uh with
republican
minority leader kevin mccarthy is up on
youtube right now and of course the full
thing is up ad
free and early at rubyreport.locals.com
have a great day everybody get out there
breathe some fresh air take your dog for
a walk
stretch your neck maybe do some yoga
lift some weights do a little cardio
god bless you i'll see you tomorrow